we all use wasd to play games on PC but
why well we can thank one man before
there was Faker and simple there was
thrush he was one of the first pro
Gamers ever and he was the Quake God and
you have him to thank for the way we
play games today when most people
started playing games back in those days
you just use the keyboard and then over
time people realized that the keyboard
had a fixed rate of turn so if you
wanted to turn left you know it would
kind of go like that so you wouldn't be
able to flick it was as simple as thresh
using wasd in his left hand and his
Mouse in his right hand because that's
what felt most comfortable it was one
man who's at the default standard for PC
gaming and it's pretty much what
everyone uses and agrees on but we still
need to decide what we used for jump
scroll wheel or space bar swinging out
hasn't seen him yet Stars tickets
will jump in jumpers pit arms